right now here on bloomberg surveillance
is to have a look at some photos we're
going to Germany day in Germany we have
the g7 upcoming meeting more than 35 70
quarter protesting President Obama
Angela Merkel David Cameron and others
are scheduled to meet activists say
world leaders fail to act on pressing
global issues topics include climate
change Ebola and the economies of the
world they'll be disgusting you know
American military personnel were told do
not wear a typical us items home such as
cowboy apparel or American logo t-shirts
really that much attention number two to
celebrate ahead of world oceans day next
week go go google streetview went on a
new adventure they captured underwater
images from the Bahamas Great Barrier
Reef and Florida Keys humpback whales
sea turtles and shipwrecks can all be
explore the images will be used to help
monitor how the area's change over time
including how coral reefs change yeah I
don't use this enough I think it's
pretty cool honest yeah google c street
I don't either